money worried can feel a lonely place
but there are more crisis calls over
debt this week than any other time of
the year and for men in relationships
financial strain is one of the biggest
causes of depression it doesn't
discriminate a charity worker bank
employee even a footballer I couldn't
really help my mom couldn't help my kid
and he made me feel worthless he made me
feel a way that I didn't belong in this
world
very stressful all bills rent council
tax TV licence gas electric food water
so many things you have to pay off and
it's just all comes at you at once
takes me down to that dark place where I
feel that the only thing left is to end
my own life and it's a horrible you know
it's a horrible thing to feel it's
horrible thing to talk about but Dan
chose to talk about it to his GP he
worked seven days a week driving his
taxi in stoke-on-trent but it will take
him three months to repay the money he
borrowed to cover Christmas up in the
doctors and got prescribed medication
because of suicidal thought thoughts you
know
that's months yeah yeah the pressure of
getting the right presence for his four
children was more important than his
mental health you try and put a brave
face on and you can put things on
Facebook and you want to you want to see
him as if you're doing the best but
really it's it's really not it's really
not it's people put the Front's on
you're not I mean around one and a half
million people in England are currently
struggling with both problem debt and
mental health more than a hundred
thousand people in problem debt attempt
suicide each year and this week a record
one person every ten seconds is making a
crisis call over their debt January
particular he's just been worse than
I've seen Craig Spillane founded a
support group in Stoke last year for men
who are feeling suicidal or suffering
with depression it has more than 11,000
members after just eight months we're
hearing people that are working seven
days a week and still can't make ends
meet
just like the other day one guy in
particular was stolen a bridge he wanted
to take his own life and he worked
full-time still as the pressure of debt
reaches crisis point for many this week
people are being urged not to suffer in
silence but any sense of financial
relief may feel a long way off Sally
Lockwood Sky News stoke-on-trent